Angus Cloud the 25 year old actor who
played fezko the gentle drug dealer on
HBO's Euphoria died suddenly at his
Oakland home on Monday July 31st as of
the making of this video the cause of
death is unknown fans and co-stars were
shocked and saddened by his passing
Cloud's family said in a statement to
CNN last week he buried his father and
intensely struggled with this loss Angus
was open about his battle with mental
health and we hope that his passing can
be a reminder to others that they are
not alone and should not fight this on
their own in silence as cloud is mourned
by friends and family a number of other
actors and production staff from
Euphoria have made public posts showing
their love and commemorating his legacy
co-star Eric Dane who plays Cal wrote in
a post on his Instagram story he was a
one-off I'm truly sad storm Reed who
plays Gia shared a similar Instagram
Story featuring clips of cloud on the
show she captioned the post simply the
tears just won't stop every death is
tragic but especially so in the case of
a young Rising star-like Cloud Euphoria
may have just been the start of a long
and meaningful career and his co-stars
have taken to social media to celebrate
the talent and kindness he brought to
his work everybody gets their feeling
soon
you know Jayvon Walton who played fez's
adopted little brother ashtray posted a
picture of him in Cloud embracing on
Instagram he wrote in the caption rest
easy brother on his Instagram story
Walton made another post a picture of
him and Cloud posing and smiling with
the words forever family written
underneath
it's not cute that's my business partner
Paula Marshall who plays Marcia said of
cloud in a statement to people he was
kind and gracious and so unique you
couldn't take your eyes off him on film
or on set how lucky we all were to have
witnessed his work it was beyond
truthful every damn take my heart hurts
Coleman Domingo who plays Ally posted a
picture of himself cloud and other
Euphoria Stars posing on a red carpet
cloud is shown smiling wide as he holds
out his own phone for a group selfie
Domingo wrote and that was a smile that
was him may he rest sweetly in peace
Lucas Gage who plays Tyler shared a
similar picture on his Instagram story
simply captioned R.I.P with a broken
heart Zendaya who plays Euphoria
protagonist Rue had many scenes with
Cloud over the years she wrote a lengthy
tribute to the actor on Instagram words
are not enough to describe the infinite
beauty that is Angus Connor I'm so
grateful I got the chance to know him in
this life to call him a brother to see
his warm kind eyes and bright smile or
hear his infectious cackle of a laugh
I'm smiling now just thinking of it she
concluded with a call to support to
everyone no matter how strong they might
seem my heart is with his mother and
family at this time and please be kind
and patient as grief looks different for
everyone in addition to the outpourings
of love and grief from Cloud's Euphoria
co-stars series Creator Sam Levinson has
spoken out about the special talent he
was Levinson said in a statement
obtained by deadline there was no one
quite like Angus he was too special too
talented and way too young to leave us
so soon Levinson also alluded to the
personal struggles that cloud had been
dealing with behind the scenes adding he
also struggled like many of us with
addiction and depression I hope he knew
how many hearts he touched I loved him I
always will rest in peace and God bless
his family Euphoria was Cloud's entry
into the world of professional acting as
he was famously scouted for the par
while out walking in Brooklyn it's a
testament to his ability that he came
out so strong on the show creating one
of the most beloved characters and
imbuing his performance with a fierce
degree of honest empathy he will be
dearly missed by his friends and family
those who had the chance to work closely
with him and the many fans he reached
through the screen
if you or someone you know needs help
with mental health please contact the
crisis text line by texting home to
741-741 call the National Alliance on
Mental Illness helpline at
1-800-950-name 6264 or visit the
National Institute of Mental Health
Website
[Music]